[Musique]
de d'être beaucoup plus confortable pour
passer l'hiver alors faut continuer
c'est la politique familiale et le
nucléaire voilà qui était de base solide
de la société française bon bah écoutez
c'est vous savez on est d'une société
qui aime à renversé les piliers le
problème c'est que quand il y a plus de
piliers tous ces fonds
sur trois annulé vendredi peut-être pire
samedi et dimanche ça fait des dizaines
et des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui vont rester sur le carreau alors que
c'est le week-end de Noël si la CGT
Sudra une appelle pas officiellement à
la grève il maintiennent les préavis les
syndicales laisse le choix à chaque
contrôleur de ce joindre ou non au
mouvement d'abord moi je présente mes
excuses au nom de toute l'entreprise
pour ce mouvement et ce préavis parce
que on le sait les Français attendent
depuis longtemps ce moment pour souffler
pour partir en vacances
il a regardé une jauge qu'on a à
l'intérieur puis il m'a dit dites mais
vous n'avez rien dans votre cuve je dis
non ça c'est pas vrai écoutez on a fait
remplir la cuve il y a 5000 litres et
ben je vais vous le prouver qui a rien
5000 litres de fioul volatilisé volé
siphonné le couvent avec ses 21 chambres
grelotes on a tous une part aussi un
rôle à jouer et c'est notamment le
respect des gestes barrières le port du
masque dès qu'on est dans un espace
clos où on est nombreux comme ici donc
je vais bientôt remettre mon masque sur
Marie-Claire porte plainte le siphonneur
reste introuvable le livreur a fournit
un fond de fioul pour permettre aux deux
sœurs de passer l'hiver au chaud le
couvent de 800 mètres carrés lui est à
vendre depuis deux ans le plein n'est
pas inclus dans la négociation et puis
au Royaume-Uni les premiers billets à
l'effigie du nouveau roi Charles III ont
été dévoilés la Banque d'Angleterre et
les entreront en circulation mi 2024
s'il vous plaît si le covid repart je
pense que les collaborateurs de la
distribution y compris nos diplômés de
pharmacie dans nos parapharmacie sont
tout à fait capables de vendre des eaux
hôtels sans casser la baraque ne nous
enfermez pas dans des règles
corporatives nous pouvons faire le job
et à moins cher la rencontre a duré une
quinzaine de minutes et c'est terminé
par un immense clapping à l'initiative
d'Antoine Griezmann et d'Olivier Giroud
il y a un de mes confrères qui a laissé
son sac avec carte de crédit enfin tout
ce que vous pouvez imaginer dans le
métro il va au commissariat je vous
inquiétez pas
dans une heure vous avez tout une heure
après le mec il avait tout et bien
chapelle seul quelques mots de Griezmann
sortiront le meilleur buteur de la
compétition de sa torpeur son seul
sourire de la soirée aura duré 5
secondes avant de repartir aussitôt
arrivé à l'aéroport tu as pas un mégot
par terre c'est un pays très démocrate
envoyer
à nidalgo là-bas